oh [ __ ] the intro Aloha I'm not redoing
it I don't want to Aloha
is it an owl what are you drinking a
coffee I'm dying
oh yeah not sleep I drink coffee right
now I'm drinking cider are you hard
variety and I have a backup one see
actually so this is kind of cool anyway
welcome took an evil this is your first
well the resin evil game by Mike that's
Mary this isn't it Mary [ __ ] I don't
even have lower 3rd today the text says
we know it's upside down but the cider
is better when you shake it so they're
like you're halfway there anyway it's
like a New York cider I like it we're
recording before we go to pax you're
going we're both leaving Thursday to go
to pax yeah I ready Knievel people going
to pax I saw a few people on Twitter
saying they want to meet up I don't know
if they're Knievel viewers I wonder if
we should even have like a Knievel
meetup or at least I mean it's hard to
do because we're both working like our
regular jobs not that this isn't a
regular job but it's kind of extra so
what we liked it like what we have to do
for work I'm going for twitch so I'm on
three panels which I'm gonna plug even
though this comes out on Saturday I'm
doing PAX Amenia on Sunday so that's the
one that people who watch this will see
what are you and then I'm like running
around with partners all day Saturday
getting them like doing fun stuff in
Boots like jumping into ball pits or
like playing games or just being wacky
what are you doing
jumping in a ball pit sounds like my
Monday morning I have a few like I just
have like mainly meetings and demos and
previews and stuff okay and then like
setting up future video features use
yeah cuz kind of light up until today I
got like six extra things today now it's
kind of busy it's it's been really busy
for me because in addition to
ooh regular work stuff and PAX East I
have family in town and so I've been
like taking people to like you know
waterfalls and who do not know I will
not go there why it's just a little its
touristy but the donuts aren't very good
in my opinion wait is there another one
Portland that's good yeah like um
bluestar is like pretty popular but it's
like really delicious donuts and they
have like kind of funky Donuts - so like
voodoo doughnuts is like notorious for
being like do you want like Captain
Crunch but like on it Dona it's crazy
but you can get like delicious donuts in
like multiple places Buddha's just like
the famous one for like chucking cereal
on top of a doughnut I saw there's bacon
on one like maple bacon yes and it's not
I don't know I don't think it's the
worst I'm just saying when I take my
family I don't take them to voodoo I
take them to blue star um we yeah what
what you got to fight the plant in this
game all right
so funny yep I think that's where we're
at but what happened was was I basically
like chickened out last episode because
I was like we have an issue personally I
felt like I had an issue where I didn't
feel like I had enough ammo to
accurately like feel cool about beating
the boss well I want to talk about that
because I only have 35 bullets and then
you make I made a little bit submachine
gun but I don't like using that gun very
much you should use that more than we
were it's not like a powerful anti boss
weapon that's grenade launcher I've been
nice doing okay I have I think right now
actually you could probably store that
store what the good I won this one this
is a dispersive cartridge I need that
for the greenhouse yeah but you're not
gonna get the required materials for a
little bit and you'll you have other
item boxes along the way okay I don't
think you'll need a spark shot I think
you're good okay um well I feel better
just having more bullets
but anyway
yeah paksy stay yeah
driving up with Dan Reicher Thursday
that's so much your first on the road
trip um I don't think so unless someone
asked like a bunch of people ask but I
don't think they will
I know like Jeff and Brad do that or III
I don't know me and they enter getting
like breakfast and then leaving Thursday
around lunch would be nice six three and
a half hours from here to Boston that
sounds super fun I'm like really jealous
of you how do I keep going to the wrong
goddamn so yeah was lesson you got the
you have a new better bracelet now as
you use it
Wheatley so I have your own back into
the plant room there are a few like
manholes you didn't go down correct so I
didn't this looks okay to you right yeah
someone pointed out remember I was
trying to figure out what this Star Wars
written language was a bunch of people
on Twitter said it's Arabic and also the
so go to the panel behind you here right
oh no it's in the next room I'm sorry I
was trying to figure out what the like
coding was but it's hurt apparently
negatives of numbers and so I feel
stupid now and I didn't notice that not
as stupid as me can I tell you what
something stupid I did the other day
shows playing baba is you have you
played that yeah I just started it
yesterday I like it a lot okay so there
was this part in Baba is you all right
all right all right you know how like it
tells you the functions like baba is you
rivers flow rock yeah rock is move and
then things are like death like they're
not good for you yeah well it's it's I
couldn't read it right because I thought
it was trying to say death but it says D
no deaf eat and I was like what so deaf
eats
I don't want oh my god like that doesn't
make sense like what is this trying to
say what's deaf eat and then I died and
then my chat was like you're a [ __ ] its
defeat
oh you're streaming it that's
embarrassing
I actually give a grenade you could use
you want to worked well last time you
quit bit and then l1o you have to go 110
wins
yeah just l1 then unique that's not hit
that was earlier no I promise that's
that's on the door I saw that earlier
freaked me out
I don't think they can go through doors
though yeah
they explode quickly so you could
probably yeah okay no idea that's fine
he's dead I think you bastard there's
another one right oh you killed that one
he killed I don't know you shot it maybe
it's still alive
dude the noises the audio and this level
sucks like in a scary way like obviously
it's good but it's like me and the
laboratory okay so this one so yeah I
got a panel on the right so those are
all negatives of numbers
what do you mean that's one so that's a
one next one's a to the next one's a
three it's like a black space I see I
see I see I see exactly what you're
saying yeah I'm so I'm dumb too because
no that's not that easy to see but like
now that you're telling me it's so
obvious that this is yeah this is an 8 9
yeah I see it now but yeah I was but
someone pointed out that it's Star Wars
in language is called Arabic I think
well is this where I put in this code
that I wrote down the other day yeah
eventually I didn't think the whole code
was there though Arabic sorry well I
only have three pieces do you want me to
do it sure I thought it was worn out
like the code you saw like half of it uh
yeah you're right I didn't have the
whole code so I should wait I guess yeah
there's some yeah I think I have two and
seven is what it looks like based on
what you just told me so I'll write that
down
all right so to seven all right and then
we'll come back to that later
all right hey you're going back to the
plant room and they're like two ladders
to climb down fantastic you know you
love going down ladders see went through
there
I went kinda through here I quit this is
like where I was like I don't have
enough ammo and you were like yeah I do
and I was like [ __ ] you I'm saying I
don't
I lost
[Applause]
yeah you could just dodge them don't
worry don't throw about going keep going
down the stairs and then keep going
straight you already went left so yeah
you want to go down here now why don't I
want to kill them I mean you don't it's
pretty easy to dodge their multiple
pathways okay oh there you go a three
let's talk about this three one two
three one two three and then what am i
doing am I getting the [ __ ] out of here
yeah going back up that panel to put
that in no no okay right you're right
right sorry still run back to the port
side of the room to the control room to
where I was what about this area that's
a dead end
that's a that's where the dude with the
key car is pushed up against the window
but the tree is blocking it you gotta
use the chemicals to kill the tree to
get his keycard which I'll give you love
oh man that was cold
he's dead go run past
oh yeah don't worry go no need to waste
bullets three one two three
I do answer okay Oh huzzah
so [ __ ] popular with your ex does
that mean your method yet pigeon sorry
it was all my fans yeah he's gonna be
here no go go I hear him burping he's
doing that slow voice thing about yeah
when it sounds like you're stroking it's
that oh [ __ ] I don't wanna be here
either
this is it's the noise they make in like
all those scary movies with the girl
with hair The Grudge do their main
whatever they're all the same
I mean they're not they're different but
you'd know what I mean
might as well be fudge there's so many
sneaky spots
ooh okay this is blue now
sorry I thought that was a thing but
it's not it was just nothing this sucks
I don't want to be here ah the blood
that is not you that's like a bit odd
oh no that's a liquor oh no no someone
who died let's talk about this so
there's a server room we could try that
yeah try that
there's no power
[Music]
he's [ __ ] shadows so rude
would they're definitely not all dead I
mean obviously no tsuita from there
though you don't know if he said or not
it definitely is in Lord Oh what is that
there's a lot of blood I mean there's at
least one two three four possible
zombies in here I don't have enough
bullets for this yes you you have a lot
of bullets you have a hundred and five
knife er
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright that oh my god I
wasn't my proudest moment or any of you
poor Yadu legs in the network Daisy her
shy need the but noise that's how you
know they're dead alright well that
wasn't great for me I you'll bounce back
from the flame rounds
alright who's next
cold drink
he's alive
oh my god they're so fast okay Duke
Nukem agai ver POW right in the kisser
Wow I saw this whole video of Marky Mark
Wahlberg when you're like listening and
apparently had a catchphrase like wow
cuz a you're dead
alright control be on that table right
there I see it got it I like the fact
that like that's like in her pocket like
this [ __ ] massive trophy she's just
like got it placed in her tight-ass
pants or it's that yeah she booked it
and she shoved it up her ass
you shouldn't examine it when you get
the chance after you kill this guy fall
down thank you oh my I just leave him
he's not dangerous
you mean like non threat yeah what about
this remember there what about this guy
if he's not bobbing you don't worry
we go check that Electric thing and
examine the DNA what electric thing on
the wall the red light it's another one
of those things Murph
you got that one upstairs and the one
here
all right it's blue so down the hall
yeah what up loser what's up loser
[Laughter]
we're you hit Eric Taylor on the show no
you were right you were right I was
wrong
that's goodnight him [ __ ] it acid round
[ __ ] slay it [ __ ] kill it I didn't
see it at first
well I don't think it saw you you could
probably keep going if you wanted to
well you're gonna have to go through
that door eventually what were there -
was there another one in the ceiling
there's [ __ ] definitely another one
and I don't know what to do now oh I'm
on [ __ ] danger yeah use that and then
reload your grenade launcher what
happened I don't know is there another
one yep reload
oh yeah oh he's dead I think they wrote
that I should have realized it Jesus I
felt bad for him kind of for her the way
he came back to life
that's like how Lord Krishna stopped
like when Lloyd comes back in the
restaurant when the dude punches him and
then he pulls his heart out you know
it's Ari Dumb and Dumber oh I swear cuz
like the lines on the walls means liquor
cuz they have the nails yeah true there
naeli boys you know we're girls Who am I
to say oh I first to look at that thing
you told me to look at yeah whoo I also
make a lot of guac so I feel like I've
really earned this guac institute aha
210 it's either seven or ten just know
it's two zero six seven zero
how can you see that I mean it yeah it's
10 but it well no it's it's a zero it's
just like the outline and then the other
ones are seven you're right is there a
ten yeah they're zero two zero six seven
what [ __ ] sugar what it's like a
shooter it actually runs me the silence
of establishing an effort at two
is that is he trying to get up its ass
like slowly rising I actually have not
seen leaving Neverland yet I don't know
if I should sing Michael Jackson song I
know I haven't seen it either I even
brought myself to I just really like
Michael Jackson mm-hmm but I should
what are these stairs going
hey high up me Camila I swear when they
die their ass is slowly raised into the
air don't mess up that's the way we like
to [ __ ] sorry I didn't think you were
gonna finish it that's like a zombies
favorite tune ski mm-hmm two ciders and
I say whatever the [ __ ] I want
Oh hear it I don't hear anything
oh I see him oh he's like got him
that song is another verse shut the [ __ ]
up if that's the guy in the stairs I'm
gonna be mad okay it's a new guy be mad
at him oh I see him alright let's talk
about this so this room what sorry they
had the mic it leads into the lobby
Sampada oh he's a screamer in me I am so
sick of that guy shoot this one's legs
and then sneak around her and then Wyatt
just go around around oh yeah
I go rap
oh I thought that was something I could
pick up pepto-bismol oh thank god
another oh oh no that's it you need to
go go back down those stairs everybody's
turned veggie feed they keep coming back
again and again burn them all burn them
into their whole body is black as ash
there's no other way once you explore
this room go back down the stairs you
just came up so you can use the signal
modulator up in this door oh yeah good
point do that and then bastard to that
red light thing past the what about this
guy Wow again a little arm here well
pitting errs though
okay so you want me to solve that thing
on the walls oh yes the quickest way to
get there he's still doing the Thriller
now I killed the liquors but the zombie
in here is still very much alive
I think you can avoid them
where is he oh there he is once you get
to the white thing you know pause MuRF
error oh you got examine it in your
inventory first got it
Iggy's you're right stick as well I
think yeah and then what
I don't know how to do this it looks so
close
know what I go like go yeah there you go
now press yeah I go back and then insert
it now you do that upstairs with the
muff as well you got it honey
I prefer downstairs them off girl
all right now you go through those doors
hey buddy which door any of them that
were this the one to your server and you
do both
I do the server room for since it's a
dead end
[Music]
sir I hardly know her
nice yay all right I might put some of
this away I don't need all this or do i
or do know you could probably make some
more bullets you know decent on a
handgun
wait go back oh that's that it's a door
all right all right so I could combine
these high-grade dumb powders gunpowder
shut up um but that would make machine
gun ammo and I'd rather make regular
bullets impossible I hate guns
okay so um I don't think you need that
trophy right now okay I have four
gunpowder's should I take two out and
make bullets that's what I want to do
yeah you could combine a large gunpowder
with a regular one that'll give you
double the bullets damn it
cool yeah um I already I should have
saved after I did that but I'm sure it's
fine I'll just not die oh how am I on
health I only have one green I should
get a full heal just in case don't you
think yeah I'm trying to remember what
happens in the next life 3 the next door
where am I going back the way oh right
yeah yeah go down right left
but I [ __ ] don't know what I don't
know what I was thinking
where the [ __ ] is my flashlight use it
yeah the auto flashlights are nice
sometimes but I would still like it to
be manual yeah like what you can see in
there
lady you feel confident pointing a gun
into nothing No
is that a bottle of wine no no no like
where is her [ __ ] flashlight she
conserving battery hey what's up down on
the ground get her other leg yeah I
think she's dead I think this game could
have been called I think she's dead I
think she yeah all right I think she's
dead
oh you can use that computer what was
that noise I have no idea
Rickman knows us all right I'm caught
right can you believe that bastard cool
your jets [ __ ] well I guess he's is
the bus for now anyway have you seen my
Hilux anywhere I put a secret on the
bottom so you couldn't make our little
meeting fine don't worry about the
greenhouse inspection I'll give you
something real simple to do put together
the budget estimate for the next for the
year after next and get it done tonight
we're under attack people are dead east
areas cut off we can't operate the
bridge with the wristbands we have
where's that bastard Cartwright
plant 43 is going wild please reply um
do you remember Suzy the cheerleader
what a great gal we were both into her
all right of course she wasn't into
nerds same old story I still like the
quarterback I started to give you back
those comics and games I borrowed anyway
all onto my D&D characters please I
don't know what she's not into us oh my
god in power authority
Scyther nerd see what we do to nerds
around here get me back my mage is she
[ __ ] dead this is the issue
Oh No look nightmare fog from Dark Souls
you don't want to go in there hello
she's funny she's got jugs something is
gonna come at me
don't I need the thingy
no you still need to fill it up first
this is to cool it down
or definitely other items in here though
dead wait wait wait do that hold on
don't press anything
hold your pull your knife out again it
looks like his hand is your foot a
little bit yeah it's my um that might be
it in here honestly
alright that's it for now sweet you can
use the power thing on the upstairs muf
thing on the old us [ __ ] you best be
dead I'm sick of it I think she's dead
I'm sick and tired of eating soon tired
oh I don't know I'm sick and tired of
being a no bike-o I'm sick and tired of
having nobody so it goes all the way
around is it faster to go right no left
it's still fast it's the faster go left
yeah you'll go to that storage room and
then you'll be near that other power
panel just look at for zombie oh there
is one I left one in here that's fine
it's Dodger was that noise that's the
scary noise that's the scary noise for
the ones with bubbles on them I don't
know what that means you do know what
that means other groups
Oh balls they're so fast shut up one
more one more yeah
onward excelsior is he dead yeah no
regrets
is there another one come on
can I dodge this um yeah they go far
left get ready to l1 if she catches you
come on
the presentation room no your own back
to the north side so left Oh like
through the main shaft yeah that Red
Room main shaft yeah just follow
followed that show the main one
is it security room that's the red one
oh the NAP room mm-hmm
every that dude that's like passed out
in the bed after his name oh the guy who
never left the NAP room yeah that's me
get your mo to get through the hours of
work yeah I mean got a nap you know
well I guess we're going this way hello
sir ma'am it's through the door at the
end and then you'll have the power panel
thing feel like six guys in that
cafeteria
and you want the muff you can set that
before you put it on yeah I need to turn
it to muff it's set to muff you know
what I mean yeah
ah you better go
no no stop stop it oh nevermind my
instincts are spot on
yeah wait my [ __ ] knife you idiot
I can't believe these idiots think I'm
working I've been in the NAP room for
eight days I used to when I'm working a
movie theory which will remain unnamed
because I don't maybe my boss is a
Knievel person um no she's not
I used to text my friend to clock me in
so I could finish watching movies is
like our max lunch break was 40 minutes
40 minutes mm-hmm hey what does nothing
say what what did his note thing say it
said um I'm like super smart I'm
definitely gonna get out of here I will
not die I will not and then it ended ha
said something about how he was gonna
like win the Nobel Prize or something
did you though huh did you or like no
brains right no but prize no no left arm
prize no no humorous phrase I'm dying in
a weird pose right and so you can use
the bottom of the DNA trophy that code
where you wrote it down right yeah I did
but like where do I be in the same
console he did for
first one yeah yeah you got to go back
all the way back yeah oops oops I don't
know where I am I think if you were an
animal you'd be a cat because didn't you
say suddenly yeah cuz when you do that
when you like say like man you sound
like just this evil little [ __ ]
steve me my videos I'm a cat
the piping here's some work
okay so where am I going now to the
greenhouse control room up north okay so
through the through the room to your
left
yeah so like what hi Carl
he's always here you know when you need
him
this is Paco this is like the scariest
image it's just so horrifying
[Applause]
nice
he's dead why are there always two in
here whoa
- bullets - little ball no two bullets
two balls no no yes Emma she gun where's
the last one where's the last ball you
got him
there's always two in here did you ever
notice that yeah they like respawn or
something okay well if I remember
correctly six zero two seven two zero
six seven two zero six seven oh wait
yeah all right so now what are we doing
you'll get the drug and then you got to
bring it back downstairs to cool it off
and then bring it back up here to kill
the plant yeah maybe not you could
probably make another like submachine
gun combo a regular hint combo where
there's not a saver box in here no you
don't really need to you killed
everybody on the way no I did it
there's a guy in hearing yep you can
easily dodge him so where am I going
am I going down the rustic lab ladder oh
no I'm going to the left yeah and then
down the ladder I know wait no hold on
hold on you need you do need a save box
you need the drug dispersal vial or
whatever in this file so I'll just go
back right mm-hmm well know the quickest
way to get go yeah go back to the save
box and then come back here though yeah
so I was gonna go to here and then down
the ladder and then up this yeah
stay dead you [ __ ] no music [ __ ]
with you
no it's not if there's a dude oh the
music is honest and me and remember a
scene before every time the music's
going you know not everybody's dead yes
do I need this find the magic in the
modulator yeah hold on to it just in
case I'm not sure honestly alright so I
need the dispersal cartridge and I would
like to make more bullets like already
have a regular gun
during your inventory I just get another
ten right you do it now you have a bunch
of large ones you can combine couple
large well so what are you saying I
combined a regular one with a large one
give you like 19 bullets 29 or something
look at my hair
haha speaking of the grunge
thank you
okay
let's go beaches that's what she sounds
like
why she's German
let's go pretty dispersion violin 2000%
now think you're set
oh there's one no no don't don't
if he's not bothering you all right
you just gotta shoot the balls you know
like if nothing else like before about
before it becomes a problem
oh no I'm sorry you already type in the
code I do it now we're gonna avoid this
one there yeah just go Colette yeah
it's checking out the sights oh that guy
freaks me out puzzles no puzzles no
puzzles what yeah you can only fill up
the middle one no no sorry you fill up
the middle too
yeah did I do it right no yeah nope
now switch the press the blue button now
the blue one
green-blue you don't know what you're
doing no wait a second
you're an idiot mm-hmm
there you go nice what
what I'm laughing at you and that's what
oh there you go
nice what you you don't know how this
puzzle works
no no no okay now do the red button blue
button green button now
blue red button blue no that won't work
this is right no no red and now green we
did it with our amazing brains
let's go cool it off I think you have to
hurry really yummy um so go down the
ladder you got that
don't worry bad good on the ladder like
to get through the greenhouse just to
the cooling lap body okay so we're gonna
go we're gonna take a little letter
yeah
[ __ ] you yeah I heard him
I did too only I'm classic low temp
testing okay
down the hall to the right
I already forgot that's the server room
so all the way down the hallway wait I
could also save it in that save room
right there I pick this up next up so so
we know what we're doing but I think
this is gonna trigger a few things
okay are you sure yeah up to you you can
go pull it down and put it put it in its
do you have stuff to do um sort of
I'll do it real quick okay
low temp testing pull it down there then
I think going back up the ladder would
be faster than the stairs I think you
you're but moved I saw that huh
like one of those things the arcade
where you can never get the thing you
want I mean to get anything at all is
typically a win in my book I think you
have to kind of hurry upstairs now I
don't know if that's true they kind of
tell you though that it'll cool off or
warm up so now I'll go put that back
into the first room with a window with
the dude pushed up against the window so
just go up the ladder up the ladder up
the stairs the ladder I think is gonna
be oh actually a good point maybe this
stairs be faster at this point no no I
open the map oh here's the stairs I
think the stairs are faster no no no no
stairs bottom right the ladder is faster
Eagle as I can't remember if you're
going yeah you're gonna look group
yeah the ladder will be faster cause you
go to that control room you're right
Megan actually being in this place alone
Oh
what up all not alone we've got Cindy
over there being a joker cool your jets
Cindy chill the [ __ ] out Cindy it's
Friday what day is it god
yeah get out of there run the other way
[Applause]
running and now I'm out very nice night
don't ya gonna die but put in that green
thing left yeah
my [ __ ] heart AHA its Hank are those
guys dead to you see through the window
what I can't see through the window it I
think they should be dead maybe not
though if not just give a submachine gun
out maybe yeah there's go fast
probably a ticket yeah hard right it
will be faster never mind there's a
brute oh my god
what am i doing when I get that
wristband uh you could probably use
grenades or not you have pretty plenty
of handgun ammo there's so many of them
like oh actually there's no one to your
right you could just no no you can't go
there I'm sorry um I have to go that's a
girl
where is where did they drop him it's in
the it's in the top right in the earth
sorry on the left oh yeah here here so
the fastest way will be going up the up
the piper to the right there's just so
many of them
like look at this let's go you like
bling now get a bunch oh yeah you could
probably go now they're not they're not
in your way but don't know there's too
many like I won't be able to get back
safely
ranae's might be worth it at this point
grenade launcher
wait oh god I thought they did nothing I
think it's it is doing nothing no no the
other one died it just didn't explode
his balls I mean if they're both aren't
gonna explode then why am I going back
yeah immediately back yeah it's red you
could combine that with a bracelet
actually no don't do that yeah it's red
if there's oh I see we're saying it
might be that part at the very end south
[ __ ] I forgot to reload ah oh [ __ ] I
haven't saved
I think you got an autosave hopefully
I'm so dumb I yeah see what that brings
you it might have done an autosave after
he killed the plant oh god where did it
put me I thought it got both of them
yeah me too
shibi acid doesn't do that much oh this
isn't that bad oh yeah you did it it did
save after you killed the plant or no
maybe you still have it I don't know I
still have it okay yeah you could save
now and then or you couldn't kill the
plan then save let's let's do what we
did and then be done okay I got it
oh yeah I'm not sure that like you acid
rounds might not be best it doesn't seem
like it the submachine gun might just be
your best bet to hit the balls or
whatever I'm so bad at hitting the balls
he's like flame rounds would be flame
rails would be way better but I don't
know if you want to go if you're gonna
go to say box you might as well just
save it at that point so yeah I would
just go yah yah yah yah yah yah yah yah
you have to fight our way out
my fellow American no I'm scared when I
start talking like yeah okay go go don't
worry about him
that's [ __ ] I'm not it look like you
were in his range dude they're so Ricci
it's really annoying
alright you got it this time do I though
yeah like they can maybe touch me that's
the problem yeah but maybe you just need
to shoot like one of his balls just to
staggering that's what I think what I
need is a [ __ ] item equipped that
saves me I don't have any equipment that
protects me you know
that's so stupid that this stuff doesn't
kill them I'm sure there's some more
reason why this doesn't make them I
don't want to do this again I wish I had
one safety item now you got it yeah
[ __ ] you
yeah yeah walk alright but now this is
where it got me
yeah just go straight for the door yeah
you got it
yeah no no I oh they might be in this
room though oh god just keep going
you're not coming are we going where am
I going
uh to the verification room you follow
that the save room yeah yes the
presentation room please well there
might be guys in here though Oh somebody
yeah oh but let him let them follow it
no it does hurt him
thanks for Nate but it takes a little
bit wait let him die yeah there you go
okay sweet I'm not doing this scene
again that dude I'll do that podium
actually no no no leave that for next
time so you remember what we remember
what we're doing oh nice
you ended it on a success Jesus oh I
think I think you speak for everyone
when you say I think I pooped oh I think
my Pam Lord sorry
wait that was rough yeah well you got a
lot done yeah
so you go in Boston yeah I will see you
in just a few days uh let's get a drink
word all right well I'll see you around
thank you guys for watching thanks for
hanging out I II will be back oh yeah
have a good rest of the weekend yeah
we'll watch effects India tomorrow
Mary's in it yeah please come hang out
the dog walker is making an appearance
and we probably have like one or two
more episodes left in this game
well Claire scenario nice they'll
haven't decided what we're doing after
maybe the other scenario maybe something
new maybe right sweet nice joyful Hey
see you next week bye
thanks for watching